herr ischinger große freude und ehre
dass die bei uns sind sie waren ja über
jahre über ein jahrzehnt der engste
mitarbeiter von hans dietrich genscher
der vielleicht größte aus politiker war
in deutschland seid herzlich willy
brandt oder gustav stresemann hatte wenn
sie teil der aktuelle außenminister maß
war am wahlabend in unserer sendung und
hat für meinen geschmack erstaunlich
klar gesagt dass die größte bedrohung
für die stabilität und die
weltgemeinschaft im moment der
expansionsdrang wirtschaftliche
militärischer natur
der volksrepublik china sei jetzt ist
beiden jemand der sich als vizepräsident
besonders dafür gerühmt hat sehr sehr
enge kontakte nach china zu haben mich
da ist kommt er hat sogar gesagt er hat
sich dafür berühmt das ist es gibt
keinen amerikanischen politiker der
engere kontakte zur chinesischen regime
hat glauben sie sowie trump seine
angebliche nähe zu russland sozusagen
diese kleine wolke war seiner
präsidentschaft schwebt dass die enge
beziehung von beiden zu vielen
funktionären der kommunistischen partei
chinas ihm irgendwie dass wir immer
auslegen könnte dass er dass er dazu
klimafreundlich ist wie gesagt die
allgemeine allgemeine haltung ist china
bedroht im moment die welt stabilität
also ich sehe das ehrlich gesagt werden
anders joe biden hat in diesem jetzt zu
ende gegangenen wahlkampf mehrfach
gesagt er will be tough und china also
ich werde hart sein mit china es ist
doch so dass wenn sie mal das ganze
spektrum der amerikanische aus
betrachten dann gibt es ein paar wenige
punkte in denen sich demokraten und
republikaner im amerikanischen senat in
der amerikanischen politik mehr oder
weniger einig sind das ist die das ist
das ist so bei der konfrontativen form
der auseinandersetzung mit china also
joe biden würde glaube ich auf großen
widerstand stoßen wenn er jetzt
versuchen würde sozusagen soft und china
auf beeten
ich glaube unser problem wird sein dass
die amerikanische politik auch unter joe
biden eine relativ harte politik
gegenüber china sein wird und dass wir
es gar nicht so leicht haben werden
europäische internet deutsche interessen
deutscher exportinteressen deutsche
interessen nicht nur konfrontation mit
china zu betreiben sondern sondern den
interessen unserer wirtschaft an annan
vertiefung der gegenseitigen handels und
investitionsbeziehungen nicht im wege zu
stehen
also diese der richtige und der falsche
umgang mit china
das ist aus meiner sicht eines der ganz
großen herausforderungen die uns in den
kommenden monaten und jahren gegenüber
stehen und wir sollten nicht davon
ausgehen dass joe biden plötzlich sagt
alles gut mit china ich werde jetzt mit
sahin nicht treffen
und da wird harmonie ausbrechen das
passt die die gegenwärtige amerikanische
landschaft auf einen seiten demokraten
und republikanern überhaupt nicht rein
und das würde ich könnte ihm auch so
nicht aber ich denke für die serie sehr
interessante antwort ich habe noch eine
anschlussfrage ich habe mich in den
letzten tagen bei mir die aufgabe
zugefallen ist etwas über beiden zu
schreiben habe ich die membran von
robert gates dem quer gelesen robert
gates war er verteidigungsminister unter
obama und somit dient er auch unter
vizepräsident biden im gleichen kabinett
und dort steht ein bemerkenswerter satz
dort steht beiden ist es unmöglich
beiden nicht zu mögen als einziger
menschen zu den kannst du jederzeit
hingehen der hat immer ein ohr für dich
aber der nächste satz lautet leider muss
man nur sagen dass er in sämtlichen
außenpolitischen fragen der letzten 40
jahre immer falsch lag also er war zum
beispiel gegen dieses special operation
gegen osama bin laden gesagt eine
unfassbare eingriff in die souveränität
von pakistan das darf man nicht machen
er war auch gegen die er war auch strikt
gegen die hat sich laut ausgesprochen
gegen die ausschaltung des iranischen
terror fürsten zu dem man könnte die
liste jetzt weitermachen war natürlich
auch gegen die verlegung der botschaften
jerusalem hat auch vorausgesagt das ist
als ob man ein streichholz in einen wald
schmeißt das wird diese ganze region in
brand setzen wenn wir das machen was ist
geschehen
es gab einen friedensvertrag oder
mehrere friedensverträge das heißt aber
noch mal auf den satz von robert gates
robert gates ist ja nicht so ein
konservativer scharfmacher sondern die
gesagt verteidigungsminister unter obama
und er bezeichnete beiden als
außenpolitisches desaster muss man sagen
also auch hier sehe ich das ein bisschen
anders was ist denn die funktion des
amerikanischen vize präsidenten wenn der
sich entpuppt als ja-sager der alles was
das nation der nationale sicherheitsrat
oder alles was der präsident und sein
außenminister vorhaben immer nur
sozusagen mit applaus bedient dann hat
er seine rolle verfehlt ich glaube dass
joe biden sehr bewusst als
bedenkenträger bei all diesen
schwierigen fall aufgetreten ist und
ehrlich gesagt habe ich für manche der
position die er damals betreten hat
vergleichsweise viel sympathie also das
mag ja sein dass er auch häufig falsch
lag mir liegen alle in der außenpolitik
werde häufig falsch weil außenpolitik
und vorhersehbare fragestellung ständig
produziert die frage ist die frage ist
und da habe ich eigentlich großes
vertrauen in schweden ist der fähig
zuzuhören ist der weg sich rat geben zu
lassen ist der fähig einen nationalen
sicherheitsrat um sich zu scharen
wer nicht aus ja sagern dann aus klugen
und erfahrenen männern bestehen da
glaube ich jedenfalls soweit ich den
senator beiden kennengelernt habe und
den vize präsident biden
da glaube ich hat sich ein relativ gutes
gefühl glaube da können wir
vertrauensvoll davon ausgehen dass wir
mit diesem team was ich da konstituieren
wird in den kommenden monaten gut
zusammenarbeiten können vielleicht nicht
immer ganz harmonisch aber jedenfalls
vertrauensvoll
wir sind bild und wie ihr liefert dir
deine news auf youtube zum nächsten
video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren